foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice hi I'm John deloney
joined here by best-selling author and
good friend Rachel Cruz we are taking
your calls on money life relationships
work oh give us a shout toll free triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is eight eight two five five two two
five and Rachel can't she can't even
can't take it anymore she's got huge
news what is it I'm so excited to
announce today is the launch of a new
podcast out by the Ramsay Network smart
money happy hour we're so excited she
can't hide it she's about to lose
control and I think she'll like it
thank you okay tell me about this yeah I
know so George Campbell and myself uh we
were just talking this was this was like
probably 9 10 11 months ago and we were
like man we need a fun just quick you
know 30 Minute Podcast every week
talking about what's going on in the
world with money because there's always
something interesting right whether it's
the Royals are in the news uh
uh is that interesting
oh yeah because then you like tie in
money and you're like okay so how does
like like tell me all about them or like
um I mean even pop culture right or
translations JLo and Ben what's up let's
talk about weddings like we're gonna we
just are like there's things going on in
the world that connect to money and we
need a place to talk about it so it's
two friends happen to be money experts
armed with a cocktail and we're gonna
just chat about money in life and it's
really exciting so anyway so the there's
two episodes that dropped today again
smart money happy hour uh if you love
podcasts go and subscribe but please
listen give us your feedback because uh
yeah George and I we love it and it's
somebody who's Sat by YouTube in real
life and listened to y'all just go it's
so fun it's basically like that so I
know that's what I mean so far it's
recorded put out there so it's That's so
exciting we're making money fun one more
time smart money happy hour so go
subscribe listen to wherever you listen
to podcasts every listen to podcast
fantastic smart money hap happy hour and
there's a drink of the day we are we
have a we have a cocktail each episode
so you'll get actually the recipe for
that the breakdown of how much it costs
to make at home versus a restaurant
money making money fun all of it we're
making money fun again I love it making
money fun again way to go Rachel all
right let's go to Kathleen in Milwaukee
Wisconsin what's up Kathleen
hello what's up
hi okay I was calling
calling to both of you and I was I was
calling we're in step four five and six
and um I've got two kind of youngish
kids and a job and so they you know they
change out of toys and they change out
of clothes and the house can become
overwhelming and so I would love to just
I feel good about when I give it to
friends and family but there's some
stuff that I would love to just like
encourage and give to you know a
donation place but then I have to tell
you Ramsey in my head saying sell
everything so the kids think they're
next so like so how do I like kind of
how do I balance that of like my house
is not paid off but we are in four five
and six so I mean I I could always you
know we're always
like where do I feel like I'm wasting my
time versus wasting my money
um or my money making opportunity or
does that make sense yeah great question
absolutely well I think the whole sell
so much stuff the kids think they're
next applies really with the gazelle
intensity of baby step two so when
you're getting out of debt it's like
you're trying to get 10 bucks wherever
you can I mean it's just like any dollar
that goes towards paying off your debts
gets you that much closer to being debt
free so a lot of that intensity and that
verbiage really for me is a sign for
baby step two you're in baby step four
five and six so yeah you're trying to
pay off the house but if you sell a pair
of your kids shoes for eight bucks
but yeah sure it's eight bucks towards
the mortgage but I don't really I mean
it's not the end of the world like at
that point now if it's like 800 that you
could sell something that's probably
worth it so it's really gonna you're
gonna have to look to see okay what yeah
what's worth it and what's not and I can
tell you Kathleen on on my end we I
rarely sell anything I mostly give stuff
away I text pictures from like kids
clothes and shoes to neighbors and and
family like you said or I just put them
in a big trash bag and take it to
Goodwill I mean like I'm I'm I don't
spend the time you know there but I'm on
baby step seven do you know what I'm
saying so like it's kind of like where
you're at so maybe step two I'd be
selling everything and get what you can
to pay off that Consumer Debt where
you're at it's gonna depend on the price
point and if it's worth the hassle uh
for you and then when she gets baby step
seven that's when you're like hey yeah
it's not bad to sell stuff but also you
have the freedom to be like I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna be able to give
give a bunch oh good well as I say last
thing and if it's like kids toys I know
for our for our house it's like Sonic
kid meal toys that are bro I'm like
trash trash like probably I don't want
to give this to anyone because this is
like a curse to you and I don't want you
to like have this like it's terrible
terrible yeah if somebody brings a bunch
of Happy Meal toys to you they're not
your friend they don't like you question
their relationship
um yeah I similar to Rachel I look at
this as baby steps one two and even into
three is about survival
four five and six and seven is about
creating a life that is worth living
right so
um I Rachel the way I break this down is
is this what's my hourly wage I'm going
to pay myself to do this thing even as
much when it comes to mowing my yard and
part of that's meditative and counseling
for me is just being out on the mower
for a while but I asked myself
if I'm going to take an hour of my day
and that's the most precious resource I
have which is my time now that I'm not
running for my life anymore
what am I going to get for this hour and
if it's eight dollars I'm probably not
gonna I'm probably gonna give it away
and bless somebody with it and move on
with my life if it's 800 dollars
I'm not worth that much so I'll make
that trade right I'll definitely make
that trade so hope that helps Kathleen
yes yes thank you some of it I think is
changing your identity from trying to
not die to
how do I build a life that I that's
worth living is that fair yes definitely
are you struggling with that part of it
um
no just maybe
just maybe the guilt of it of like could
I could I be doing more but then but
yeah but then the the like you said with
the analogy of the mowing the lawn like
is it really worth it running around the
city for five dollars so not with our
gas prices absolutely not yes unless you
drive a Tesla like Rachel it's just it's
for sure now that's for sure
um hey I I think we under under talk
about this Rachel is Shifting identities
from one of running for your life and
one to how do you live because I think a
lot of us
we grew up in households where debt was
just the way things were and so when it
goes we moved to a baby steps four five
and six and seven
we're creating a life that we've not
ever seen right or we especially have
never felt it what's it like to not be
looking over your shoulder all the time
and it feels irresponsible if you've
been looking over your shoulder your
whole life yeah how do you settle into
that well there isn't it I love that you
ask the identity question because for so
many people getting out of debt it's it
like that is life that is everything
you're working towards everything and
the moment it ends yes you get the
freedom and the peace but a lot of
people are like oh my God what do we do
what do I do I don't know what to do now
where do I focus my time am I in it like
it is a weird period you've got to be
married yeah that's right that's gonna
go on a date now right yeah and that's a
whole other candle all right triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsey Show we'll be right
back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by Rachel Cruz
and we're taking your calls on money and
relationships and work in your mental
health and life all of it triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Sean in Phoenix what is up Sean
hey guys thanks for uh having me here uh
you got it what's up question
is uh so kind of backtracking a little
bit in like beginning of the pandemic
I was looking at buying a house in order
to qualify for that house like I was
going to be running out my old one so I
needed like to get that place rented
quick for the income they wanted to
include that um in the qualifying
process there
I ended up renting it out to my cousin
uh Stars kind of aligned his lease was
coming up in his landlord at the time
was going to be rent like increasing up
to like 1800 1900 something like that
I said hey if you want to move in my
house it's not only bigger it's closer
to your work here and I'll run it to you
for like 1600 and everything's been good
uh he's been there since like May 2020
and they're coming out like I mean
passing the two-year Mark here and
that place currently rents wood rent for
around 2500.
um and I'm just curious and like if I
should
increase the rent like what the
expectation like what how I should do
that if I should at all I guess uh to
family there
uh I
I don't have a problem with you raising
rent like I I think the the challenge
here is a there's something in your
spirit that's not settled and B there's
something relational that has kept you
from just sitting out and having this
conversation
yeah
I just wanted to make sure
yeah yeah you're not a bad guy for
raising the rents right I mean yeah
you're not it's this isn't a Ministry to
him right this is your investment uh and
you guys have worked out well then and
so I mean like so I want to get to like
the heart stuff like what John was
saying but on a tactical level you know
if it was me I think having the
conversation of hey so 2500 is is market
value I'm not going to take you there
this year like I mean I think if you
went almost a thousand bucks up I mean I
think you could and there's nothing
morally wrong with it but it's a little
bit of a whiplash like yeah that's right
yeah is there a middle ground to say hey
I'm gonna raise you to 2 000 this this
year and just expect probably another
bump next year I might you know maybe
I'll give you a little bit of a discount
for Market rape since we're family uh
and and if you Sean can afford that and
that's okay
um then that's okay but I I wouldn't man
I I wouldn't I understand why you're
hesitating and I want you to break that
down with John a little bit more but
because it is awkward yeah I think you
nailed it Sean I think there's what
you're doing isn't right or wrong I
think it's just business I think how you
do it is going to be do you do it with
dignity or do you send him an email and
says hey I'm raising rates a thousand
dollars a month effective whatever or do
you call them and or go visit him in
person and say look here's the deal man
this thing's gone up so much I can't in
good faith I can't continue to afford to
run it this low do you want to stay in
it because this is what the rent's gonna
be for you versus with the market did
you see what I'm saying there's a right
way to do it giving him an option is a
great idea too because it says dignity
that he chooses then it's you being a
grown-up and saying here's what I'm
choosing
I'll give you the opportunity to be an
adult and choose to
so I guess like the the thing was like I
don't mind helping him out so like
because he's been wanting to get into a
house himself and I've been sending them
houses like I know about house prices
have gone up and stuff but I'm starting
to see it cool down here in Phoenix and
I sent him a house I like just recently
dropped like 50 000. and then he's like
you just had full of excuses on terms of
why he can't can't do it and it's like
you know I don't mind giving you a
discount to help you get ahead but then
if you're taking that money and then
going on vacations with it and doing
this in terms of what I've seen it's
like that's why that's why you need to
get at it like I'm getting squeezed a
little bit well you are because you're
asked you have expectations of him that
y'all did not agree on
he didn't agree that he was going to
live under market value for two years
and save it for a house that's what you
want him to do and so now you're getting
mad about an arrangement that you don't
even have
yeah and so if you sit down with him and
say I will let you be six months for six
more months we're gonna ride this out or
three more months and you can get a
house but after this I gotta go back to
market value here you've had two and a
half years yeah here's the agreement
that's that's a totally different thing
but it's really not fair for you to get
mad about an arrangement that doesn't
exist in real life
true uh yeah we haven't discussed on it
there so I guess it's just more I've
been just like asking around and stuff
and I've gotten my my wife uh we're
talking about and that difference of
opinion like you know I'm gonna call
call the Ramses and see what they say so
so the best answer Rachel and I can give
you in this kind of situation is what
would we do with our family and I would
do exactly what we have just would have
said is I'd call my cousin and go grab
some coffee and say how's your life how
are you doing the market has shifted
dramatically it's it and so I've got to
have to put this up at a higher rate I'm
making that choice not blaming anybody
I'm owning that choice because I'm an
adult and I'll cut you this deal for
this long but then I'm gonna have to
make a move and if you want to stay I'd
love to have you as a tenant you've been
a great tenant if you've got to go I
totally understand you've got to leave
and really you're framing the
conversation as you're giving them
permission to leave not that you are
kicking them out yeah right and he makes
a choice he makes the choice yeah yeah
so yeah just like Sean that's awkward
though here it's yes yes be clear and
there's another thing for those of you
because real estate I feel like people
love it's just a hot topic of like
investment real estate having rentals
passive income all of it but always
always raise the rents if you're a
landlord even if it's 20 bucks 50 bucks
because there is something that said if
you just keep the same rent for three
years suddenly sometimes the renter can
feel entitled to no no you can't raise
my rent it's been the same and I've been
good and as a landlord like no no what
he just experienced I just ran comps for
the first time in three years and now
yeah so always if there is if you have
that in your life if you have a rental
raise it even again 50 bucks that has to
be a lot but enough of movement there
that has ever heard stagnant okay there
you go John did you learn something I
just I just learned real estate I'm a
Real Estate Mogul off arrows learning
all about these wild conspiracies and
everything and ancient things but there
are some weird stuff in the world we
won't do it on this podcast I learned
about uh
real estate okay hey we got a minute
left before we go to break tell me more
about this new podcast oh yes the smart
money happy hour smart money happy hour
We're uh George Campbell and I are
hosting it together and it was it's a
really casual it's a it's a really
casual podcast so it's definitely a
podcast if you love The Ramsay show
uh if you have a friend that you're like
man I really wish they would like kind
of engage their money A little bit more
and listen but if this show that you're
listening to currently is a little bit
too like intense Intense or hardcore the
happy hour the smart money happy hour is
a great kind of entryway entryway into
talking about money so yes we talk about
pop culture things going on Trends stuff
we're seeing uh it's basically the the
conversations you wish you were having
with your friends when it comes to money
we're gonna have it live on a microphone
that you get to listen to I love it hey
if you ever notice that when you commit
to change in one area of your life it's
easier to make progress in other areas I
met thousands of people on their journey
to build wealth who've accomplished
other amazing things along the way like
losing a bunch of weight finding career
that they love fixing their marriage
overcoming Stress and Anxiety when it
seems what seems impossible becomes
possible when you have a smart plan and
you turn up the focus and intensity on
your goals that's why we're bringing
smart conference to Dallas Texas on
Saturday October 22nd smart conference
is the one day event where we help you
build momentum in all areas of your life
whether you just lost your job the
credit card bills eating up your
paycheck or you feel alone in this crazy
world we got you Ramsay personalities
Rachel Cruz my myself Ken Coleman
Christina Ellis George Campbell will
join Dave Ramsey on stage to give you a
smart plan for your money your
relationships your personal growth and
your career live in person October 22nd
get your passes before they sell out
visit ramseysolutions.com
events to reserve reserve your seats
this is a fun event just saw the
timeline you have the longest keynote
did you know that John
well I mean they can't give more time
all the time and I was like wow
no here's the deal George and I will
have shorter shorter Keynotes
are full of hot air and you can't stop
talking and yeah that's that's where
they're like it's a really fun day so
come out if you're like the first one ah
it's great it's a fun event looking
forward to it
825-5225 this is the Ramsey Show we'll
be right back
[Music]
oh foreign
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Kate in Stamford Connecticut what
is up Kate
how we doing
I'm doing well how are you I'm good I'm
good what's up how can we help
okay
um in the last couple months it has come
to life that there's been some pretty
significant financial infidelity
um from my husband who got involved in
day trading and has subsequently lost
about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars whoa um I know
um it's a giant pill to swallow and one
that I'm just honestly still like in
shock about wow I just I still can't
believe it I just can't believe it
um so this is a combination of about 105
000 in personal loans and about 42-ish
in credit card debts
um all of this was like within the last
you know maybe six seven months it
happened very quickly and honestly it's
all just come out now
um and so my concern is that the minimum
amount for all of this debt combined is
about 4 800 a month which is a that's
the minimum and my question to you is
what do you think about me taking out a
HELOC loan
um which hopefully would be able to pay
off all of this debt and then it's like
a more manageable monthly payment for me
you know because
quite frankly we've got two small kids
there's 4 800 a month in minimum
payments is
it it's crippling I don't even know how
we how do you do this for the rest of
time you know because if you're only
paying the minimum that's what we're
looking at oh gosh I can hear it on you
oh my gosh one I'm sorry I'm so sorry
um thank you thank you I want a first
Norm
what's going on inside of you
you are right to be
maniacally angry and you are right to be
stunned and in shock and grieving and
upset and scared and anxious all of
those things are right okay I just don't
want you to feel like you're going crazy
you probably are gonna feel like you're
going crazy but not because your
feelings are wrong okay
um I would be having all of those things
too what is your what is your entire
homes uh what is your take home income
as a family
um
together we're at 250 000 annually okay
I'll let Rachel hop in here here's what
I want to tell you
do not make a mess
even Messier
okay okay I know you can't breathe right
now your breath will come back to you
you'll have a big salary you've got a
huge huge mess on your hands yeah what
often happens is let's take regular
infidelity okay somebody you find out
somebody love has cheated on you
romantically yeah there's this I want to
fix it I want to I want to solve all
this right this second so that we can
get back to quote unquote the way things
were
sure and what you want to do is you are
hurting so bad right now you want you've
got this magic HELOC that you want to
solve it all and you want to go do that
and take it out and just get back to the
way things were and then we'll we'll
figure it out later in a more manageable
way
yeah the best way forward is you for you
to realize your husband to realize
what you all knew before is now over
you're living in relationship 2.0
right and you've got to rebuild what
this thing's gonna look like together
and I think personally
what led your husband down this path is
something he's going to have to heal
from personally and you're all gonna
have to heal relationally and a quick
Band-Aid fix over this or just moving
debt from one arm to the other does not
solve that it kicks the can down the
road y'all gotta deal with this I'd love
to see him go get a second job a third
job and make this like crank this sucker
out on behalf of his family
and make this thing happen but
just trying to jump in and solve it and
fix his problem is is not the best thing
for your marriage for your financial
security for your kids long term
yeah Kate um not to make light of the
situation but one of my favorite quotes
from Warren Buffett which we use a lot
during the covid pandemic was people
make the worst decisions with money when
they're drunk or when they're afraid
and you are that second and so the the
fear that I hear from you which I get I
have three little kids and if that bomb
was dropped on me
um yeah you can't breathe you can I mean
the the fear of knowing how how are we
going to pay our bills how am I going to
get food on the table I feel
um this complete Whiplash in a marriage
sense from my husband the secrets that I
had no clues you're dealing with that on
one side and then the Tactical nuts and
bolts of being a mom with kids and
trying to figure out how am I going to
do this so I yeah I'm so sorry I I I I
hurt so much for you
um but I don't want you to make a bad
financial decision because you're in
fear and so what John was saying is so
right just take a breath okay and that
will come easier and easier with time
but don't getting a HELOC it moves the
problem from one to the other and yes it
can feel like okay the payments may be a
little bit different but that keeps you
guys in this mess and in this memory
longer and longer and longer and so in a
in a dream world you and your husband
sit down Kate together and you say okay
we make 250 000 you bring home probably
around fifteen thousand dollars a month
after taxes and so now we have this new
five thousand dollar payments so here's
what we can afford in our budget to pay
as is and I don't know what that looks
like for you guys we don't have time to
unpack every number of your budget but
say you have two three three thousand
dollars left at the end of your budget
in general right and then you're like
okay we gotta make up whatever the
difference is is it another two thousand
you got to make up uh and then I want
you to add on more to that because like
you were saying just paying the minimum
payment you're gonna be paying interest
and all of this stuff it just keeps
going and going and so how can you
attack it and so I want you guys to run
numbers together get a spreadsheet out
get a calculator out and just say Okay
scenario one you take an extra job and
you're gonna make x amount per month
here's how quickly timeline wise we can
pay this debt off we can pay it off in
three years and two months if you take
two jobs and you work four nights a week
five nights a week we can pay it off in
two years and eight months and run
scenarios Kate okay sit there with a
yellow pad because what's going to
happen is uh and John says this all the
time facts are your friends when you
start to see numbers not just fear in
your head and not having a plan but when
you actually see numbers on a sheet of
paper that logic is going to help help
you navigate the best decision and
um and man you you guys have a hard
three to four years ahead of you Kate
you do and yeah and that is the
unfortunate part of marriage that when
you are in a unified relationship
it is now your debt even though it was
his decision that he went down this road
and so I would the anger is real and
Justified all of it um so I don't want
you to shy away from those things
because that is very real and that's
going to be part of your healing process
towards him Kate I wish you could feel
this I can feel the anger on Rachel
right now
and what I wonder too and this is John's
Lane but I'm like what he was going
through what what was the thing right is
it is it an addict is there an addiction
there that he's like I think I could do
it it's almost a gambling feeling of
this day trading is it that he wanted
something else to be this I mean I've
like looked at every scenario and this
this can only be yeah
um it's day trading addiction it's not
necessarily gambling like at the casino
in my mind it's the same thing like it
is it comes from the same place
did you um not that this matters did you
find out on your own or did he come and
tell you
um to be honest with you I just had this
feeling something wasn't right and I
just looked at him I said tell me right
now what's happening and he just broke
down and I he only told me a little bit
at a time it wasn't that bad and then a
little bit more a little bit more and
then honestly just in the last a few
weeks did the extent of this come out so
I'm in a deer in headlights right now I
mean he's not day trading anymore and um
I have direct deposit his paycheck comes
right to me so there is no more money
too yeah but I mean now I'm left with
having to carry this burden and make the
decisions who do I pay this month who do
I not and it I'm I don't want you to
dealing with this you can't do it alone
can't do it alone you bring him and get
and if you guys have a good pastor a
good therapist a good counselor in the
area yes do that Kate and hold on the
line we're going to give you guys
um Financial Peace University and it's
not going to be the the Silver Bullet in
this situation but I I hope at least
getting on the same page
and that you guys have the same shared
goal and same vision it's going to be
really important so Austin will pick up
and give that to you guys for a year but
I'm so sorry Kate I'm so sorry I'm sick
to my stomach don't do anything for six
six months
just hang in there
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Brian in Savannah Georgia let's
see here what's up Brian
hey
hey what's up man hey thanks for taking
a call of course what's up how can we
help
so my wife is uh she's part of a
non-profit a very small non-profit they
do Christian Counseling okay and she's
kind of been uh tapped for and she's
been part of the ministry for you know
four or five years now but she's kind of
been tapped to kind of take over uh as a
CEO of the non-profit
um the uh the founder who is the CEO now
is is stepping down to basically retire
she's late you know uh late 70s but
anyhow so as she steps down uh the the
question came up or the request is that
she still gets paid
uh like you know a certain amount of
money per month
um and so which is actually a pretty big
burden because it's less than a hundred
thousand dollar annual budget probably
uh and she's getting somewhere between
two thousand twenty five hundred dollars
a month
so the question is we're not really sure
how you would handle that her stepping
into that my wife doesn't want to we
want to honor the person you know that
that that started the ministry but then
there's also the burden that it puts on
the ministry itself that it's it's kind
of hand to mouth kind of thing so we
just we wanted some unbiased opinion I
guess is what we're looking what does
she want to why does she think she's
entitled to
Eternal payments
um
because you found it I guess because she
is yeah she's the founder of me
yeah she started it and then I guess
that uh you know for her I guess that's
what she she looks at it as is kind of
like hey I started this I should
continue to be paid you know
for a while you know at least in
perpetuity as as far as she's concerned
is this like her retirement Brian was
she banking on this like was that
um I don't think it was something she
was banking on I mean she gets Social
Security I mean she's had other jobs
previously I mean this has been her the
the full-time job
um this has been a full-time job for her
for probably the past maybe seven or
eight years I guess uh and my wife we've
already talked about it we she doesn't
expect to get to get paid at all
um it'll be basically uh because it is
Christian Counseling and she gets she
gets paid when she counsels people is
this done out of a church
uh it is not out of a church no sir okay
so it has like you'll have rent you pay
and all that kind of stuff
yes sir we have rent they have you know
yeah they rent offices they have like
three or four officers they rent okay
it's actually grown quite a bit since my
wife's been part of it they they sure
they have um yeah honestly the
non-profit side you know the profit side
you sell the you sell the practice to
someone you got you know what I'm saying
like it's that but the non-profit yeah
this whole thing feels gross to me Brian
I'm just gonna be honest with you um and
I'm I'm willing to be wrong here uh so I
won't speak on behalf of the Ramsey
company I'll speak on behalf of John
deloney
um
I've worked at non-profits for the
majority of my career whether it was a
university or an educational setting or
when I was in college at a church right
um in all of those places I I was on
call 24 7 365. I showed up at hospitals
I helped design and build buildings with
Architects and Engineering for like
to expect to then leave and just get
paid on work I'm not doing anymore just
because I founded a program I started
this or that to me sounds insane
if I'm doing a job that has intellectual
property rights to it or I'm running a
business that is not propped up by the
non-profit status that I don't have to
pay taxes on it I get all these
different cuts all over the place and
I'm owning all of the risk here and then
I'm gonna sell that that's one thing
this yes this I somebody is saying okay
it's time for me to retire it's time for
me to resign then it's time for you to
retire and it's time for you to resign
um I'm just thinking here I couldn't I
can't imagine myself leaving and be like
hey Dave how about you just pay me a
salary for the rest of my life that just
seems bizarre but it seems equally
bizarre to call back of old universities
I worked for
um and say hey you should give me
something she did found it she did um
help people out she's probably benefited
from people working
um for less than market rate for a long
time because they've got Great Hearts
she's probably benefited from the
non-profit stat all the stuff and that
doesn't undermine how much work she is
but this is this is not about personal
ownership or intellectual property this
is about
I've been trying to help people for a
long time I want to keep helping people
for a long time and now I'm passing that
helping baton on to somebody else and so
I don't feel good about it
yeah and that's that's kind of where we
were at just because it's it's pretty
heavy burden you know a quarter of your
budget kind of goes to that yeah which
makes me sad for her where I'm like her
Legacy if she goes through with this it
can't even be propped up well because
I'm taking the money out of out of the
counseling center for my own good and
you could they can barely make payments
on rents and salary and stuff so from a
mathematical standpoint it's like she's
driving her own thing into the ground
which makes no sense either so uh and
let's let's be honest about two things
okay one she probably I wanna I wanna
think through her side of this I want to
be empathetic
I can't imagine that she has put heart
Blood Sweat and Tears into this thing
for years and this is a big part of her
identity and this may be a way less less
she has to have the money and more she
wants to stay connected because this
thing is part of her and that's hard
right so maybe having some way to honor
her in the community get the paper some
way to honor her will be what I think
would be worth this I mean it would be
right the other thing is this you can't
control
what she goes and does after you say
we're not going to continue to fund
we're not going to continue to pay you
she can go to trash all she can go out
and say mean things about you she can
try to close the nonprofit down then
before she she can try to do any number
of things she might be able to close it
down as the as the CEO who's leaving she
might be able to shut the whole thing
down let's cancel it you all have to be
prepared for here's what could happen
and don't be surprised by it and don't
don't let your boundaries waver
because of the loud volume and the
screaming and the yelling or whatever
might happen or the name calling or the
mean emails or whatever does that make
sense
oh yeah yeah of course yeah I appreciate
you guys all right Dave thanks for that
good luck moving forward that was that
one's tough that one's tough man oh man
all right let's go to uh Chester in
Washington DC hey Chester up against the
clock uh what's up man
yeah so uh thank you guys for having me
I do appreciate it very much so
um
let's see where I start okay so I'm I'm
about if you count student debt uh card
debt well one card debt um uh every debt
I guess combined it equals about I guess
125k
okay and uh currently I'm a
congressional staffer not a staffer
intern right
um but you are on staff and my wife
works at Cracker Barrel and recently
we've been presented with an opportunity
from a church that is uh near us to be
directors of a program they have that is
basically
um it helps people who who are homeless
of course there's a thorough background
check so it's not like violent criminals
or or any of that that are allowed but
they give them a place to stay and it
also
um like helps them find work and then
gives them a spiritual Foundation to
send them back into the world so they
don't are they going to pay you real
money Chester
four thousand dollars a month yes sir
what is your Congressional intern pay
you besides a high five oh Jesus uh
fifteen hundred a month that's right yes
um I I would I would make the move
yes sir um but one thing they're also
going to provide us a place to live not
with the people but it's like our own
place
get your debt that's awesome yeah get
your debt paid off what's that what's
the hesitation Chester
ma'am what's the hesitation
uh just
uh I don't know I'm I'm honestly man I
don't know uh my wife uh I guess she's a
lot more spiritually in tune than me and
she feels like it's the God thing
and I guess I'm starting to feel the way
too so I guess it scares me a little bit
how old are you guys I'm 27 she is 22.
do you want to do this Chester like with
your life does this sound I love helping
people that's that's why that sounds
crazy but that's why I don't sound crazy
at all we do too this is my wife's dream
as well if you do something like like
it's Christmas Chester I think it's
great I think you guys both young in
their 20s change is weird change is hard
change is scary but it sounds solid the
math works out well better better in
your favor and you guys get to do
something you love together you don't
have to be a 27 year old intern anymore
go for it go for it Chester you got it
you got this is the Ramsey Show we'll be
right back
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice I'm John deloney joined
here by my good friend Rachel Cruz and
we are taking your calls on life and
money and relationships whatever's going
on in your world give us a shout triple
eight eight two five five two two five
toll-free triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go out to
Randall and St Louis Missouri what's up
Randall
in 2019 I went into credit card debt and
you know 2020 hit went out of work for a
while let all my credit cards lapse on
me now I'm being sued by my credit card
company and I need you guys wisdom on
what to do hmm how much do you owe man
um
all together about 17
000 for this particular credit card six
thousand
are the other ones going to be suing you
in short order are you still are you
current with them
uh the other two are in collections this
one is the actual credit card company
decided to sue me okay
um how much how much money do you have
yeah
I can get a hold of about two thousand
dollars that's the max I have right now
okay dude the way you say that you're
gonna murder somebody how you gonna get
two thousand dollars
the way you just said that like I said I
can get a hold of it
my family understands that I just
started the baby steps and they're
willing to help me cover this if I can
get them to settle it's the most they'll
be able to help me with though
because my sister just had a big
Financial issue herself so okay my
mother wanted to help us both out of it
okay
um right now how much money do you make
a year
I make a little over 13 an hour
what do you do can I work full time
I'm a gas station attendant I'm also
going to college okay okay what are you
studying
accounting ironically enough
accounting huh
all right
um how are you paying for school Randall
I took out student loans at the start
but when I first found out about Dave
Ramsey I stopped taking out student
loans and I've been
barely scraping together enough each
semester to be able to cover my pocket
okay okay have you paid where are you at
for this semester have you already paid
for the full total or are you paying
in increments for this I have three
payments total I've paid two of them for
the semester I have one in November one
November okay
um
okay I don't I here's my here's my
knee-jerk reaction Randall
um the money from your mom is this just
a gift that she has Surplus and she just
says I want to be able to help you or
you expected to pay this thousand
dollars back to her
I would have to pay it back yeah I know
it would be a family loan yeah
um she needs help out at property so she
wants me to work it off instead of
actually paying her sure sure okay
here's the deal Randall it's six
thousand dollars which I know is a lot
okay that's a lot but it's not 60
000 so you have a thousand dollars to
your name you could get another thousand
from your mom as a loan uh you're going
to school you have there's a lot of
stuff Happening Here
and you get paid 13 an hour where you're
at which is drastically under what you
could there's a lot of places that are
20 25 an hour so here's what I would do
if I were you Randall because I how old
are you
foreign
ran into near homelessness right after
high school yeah
so it took me a long time to get back on
track to where most people start at
right out of high school sure absolutely
yeah you've had a hard Road this is a
lot
but I I have confidence in you Randall
and I have confidence in the numbers
that I'm seeing so I would keep your
thousand dollars as an emergency fund
and then I would go
and I would Uber drive for Uber I would
work night shifts somewhere I mean I
would go crazy work like you've never
worked before with a minimum of saying
20 an hour or whatever it is because you
there's a lot of places that are that
are hiring for much higher than what
you're doing and I just think if you get
your income up over a period of time
you're going to be able to pay this off
and I would call the credit card company
and say hey I got you know I got 500
bucks to my name and you're not going to
get anything so so either we we settle
this and we get on a payment plan and
you get that in writing to be able to
knock out a bunch of this really quickly
with a lot of work and and that that's
that's the road I want to take because I
think Randall for you
there's going to be something in this
process for you
that's going to give a sense of dignity
and I think that you know going into
debt with your mom all of these things
they sound good in the short term but I
think you have the ability to fix this
Randall I really do
Randall here's a question I want to ask
you brother
are you tired
no very much
like this has to be old like your
sister's gone through this you've gone
through this you're almost homeless you
and I could probably talk for a couple
hours over some nachos you had a rough
go of it as a middle school high
schooler is that fair
yeah yeah you're 26 you're 27. are you
just tired
yes very tired okay
here's the thing
Rachel just laid it out beautifully for
you
this isn't the moment to go cut corners
and to put your mother and your
relationship at risk by making it a
financial transaction now don't do that
stand up tall call that number back that
where there's two in you and you can say
I'm coming back from homelessness
I'm working at a gas station I'm in
school like Rachel said you can sue me I
got nothing for you
um you can put me on a payment plan at
this at this percentage rate and send me
a thing in writing and I'll settle for a
thousand dollars or two thousand dollars
that's what I can do and no the other
ones are coming too right
and then for the next 24 months man I
want you to work like you've never
worked before
can you do that
yeah we'll let me say this I know you
can will you
yes I plan on getting out of all these
deaths this is something that
has waited very heavily up in the last
few years excellent there's nobody in
your corner more than Rachel and I and
Randall we see so often I can't tell you
how many stories of this moment in
people's lives and we kind of call it
the sick and tired moment and this is
yours where you're like I'm getting sued
by this credit card company I have these
lingering things I feel like I just
can't get ahead it's just this it's one
after the next of not feeling like what
am I doing I've had it what I've been
what I have done up until this point is
not working I have to change and this is
your moment Randall this is it so hold
on the line Austin's gonna pick up uh
we're gonna send you both a copy of
Total Money Makeover Dave's book starts
the baby steps and your subscription to
finding uh to Financial Peace University
and I want you to have every dollar the
budgeting app so those three things
together own your past change your
future stuff Randall because we believe
in you you can do this this is your
moment Randall this is your moment to
say no more no more you've got this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show and during
the last break we're joined by a guest I
walk in here and only George Campbell
what's up man this feels like what
SportsCenter would be like like the
three of us hanging out talking about
the big game it would be if you knew
what sports were right
before I can be Samantha Ponder with a
bunch of guys I don't know who that is
ESPN reporter she's wonderful I should
probably watch that channel do you know
what ESPN stands for George oh dear what
does it stand for is this what the
entire show has been like so far no we
were crushing it before you should wait
seriously what is it excellent Sports
yes excellent Sports person Network yeah
good job Rachel okay so George is
joining us I don't know if we've had it
there's a big reason person co-host
thing in a while has that ever happened
has this ever happened are we making
history we've had we've had three in
there yeah you're not special sure sorry
I was trying to claim it well we're here
to celebrate Rachel we are because
George and I have have launched a new
podcast called smart money happy hour
that's right so this is something that
we've been talking about for probably
over a year now it's been a long time is
the conversations we have off mic
sometimes are the most fun we have and
so we decided to just have them on Mike
and so this is a podcast about money pop
culture it's entertaining it's casual
it's just two friends who happen to be
money experts armed with a drink in hand
having the conversations you wish you
were having with your friends that's
right so we're going to be that John's
always saying shares every episode do
you like that John I I did right in the
middle of it do you want to did you want
a glass to uh cheers well y'all are
talking about the Queen's finances I'll
just be at home out in the woods here
it's just cool I'll I'll just enjoy the
podcast okay so we're gonna give a
little bit of a sample of it yeah this
feels like a late night show it does uh
so this is a segment that we're gonna do
every episode where it's called guilty
as charged so our producer Lindsay
throws out a scenario and we have to be
honest it's like are we guilty are we
not and all of you out there get to
answer for yourselves as well so we'll
play that check it out
[Music]
all right George it's time for our last
segment guilty as charged
okay this is where our producer Lindsay
comes up with a question uh maybe it's
incriminating we don't know it's
borderline ethical I'm fairly nervous
about it and if we have done this we
gotta take a drink okay what's the
question for today Lindsay have you ever
fudged the numbers on your budget to
feel better yes
100 percent
yes oh yeah Rachel's cooking the books
all the time oh last month Grocery and
restaurants were
I don't know what we were doing I
literally look at him like I don't know
how we spent that much on food but we
did but I just upped it a little bit and
you know what I did George this is
probably fairy guilty you took it away
from the kids I took it
oh no the dog didn't eat but Rachel got
I have thrown a nail salon
um transaction into Amelia's category
I've done that before just throw it
right in because I thought she loves
nails without her consent without her
consent yep oh my goodness no I took it
out of our out of our like we have a
savings line item that will save extra
income
and I lowered it by a few hundred bucks
to finish out the food category so I
took it out I didn't even go and take it
out of miscellaneous that had like extra
money in it I was like I don't want to
move any categories this month so I'm
taking out for savings and through poor
little Amelia under the bus and I did
put a nail salon a transaction and
herself how about you have you [ __ ] so
much Pearly Gates they're gonna back
Rachel we got to talk about it before
you come in here we got to talk about
that time
you're not a very good person Rachel wow
oh my gosh you were guilty too George I
didn't hear that at all
clipped it they stopped the clip the
evidence would suggest that that's
that's what we call a tease in the
industry if you want to hear my side you
can go listen to Smart money happy hour
yeah Rachel steals from her kids George
steals from his two little French
bulldog poodle whatever those things
they don't know the difference listen so
here's the deal if you like this show I
think you're gonna like smart money
happy hour this is fun casual money
advice because money can be stuffy and
boring and stressful and no one wants to
talk about it and we're willing to have
those conversations and make it fun so
if it sounds like something you're
interested in go check out smart money
happy hour you can subscribe new
episodes drop every single Thursday the
first two are out right now I'll tell
you the titles and see if you know John
let's see if this sweats your whistle is
convenience culture worth being broke
um I would say no well you have to try
nothing go ahead it's not for you to
answer it's rhetorical the next one is
the TV network that brainwashed us all
can you guess what TV network it is MTV
no oh HGTV yes nailed it you he's like
our audience yeah I'm like you're right
here you're a Target demo I've never
been a Target demo before that's
fantastic you are you're welcome
so we've been seeing a lot of feedback
already Rachel and people are really
enjoying this we honestly weren't sure
how people would react yeah because we
wouldn't we want to educate so like
there's a point to all of the podcasts
but also it's like we can have a little
bit of fun too yes it doesn't have to be
all just like educate okay give me
something you've been talking about on
the show like you just tease the titles
well we talk about convenience culture
so a lot of Trends out there with
technology social media Amazon Google
and how it's a less psychologically
listen to you of course she does I know
I know so we talk about that I have
Alexa yeah I do I know I know I'm the
biggest seriously theorist and I have I
know the government's just listening to
very unimportant conversations in the
crew's household is what's happening
more important the government isn't
great at almost anything so the fact
that they have this technology and
they're all sitting around listening to
us I just I don't buy it nope they just
keep it on a reel somewhere just in case
yeah and in 30 years like trials
they're like
what we say
every person who makes the finalist of a
campaign of any of any significance gets
called into a room well what's hard
about Alexa is she does listen and then
it's attached to Amazon so they're like
oh we know what you need and what to buy
and then your app suddenly all the
algorithms so it makes you buy more
it's unbelievable so that's what we talk
about we Rabbit Trail into how it
affects that just was that is smart
money happy hour but we just did you
love it John you don't like it you love
it yeah no it's a fascinating
conversation I would just say like well
you should just don't have Alexa you're
near end of episode you'd be a terrible
podcast host job at least gentlemen I am
going to uh also be launching a a
podcast called sad minute where I just
say don't buy Alexa that's actually a
good idea that'd be the follow-up too
happy I'm really excited about this it
was fun and then the other episode
that's out is HGTV and we just talk
about our homes and HDTV I'm the one
right they are what you're the worst I
am though do you love HGTV all of my
heart that's a guilty pleasure it's a
guilty pleasure you should be a guest I
watch it and I'm like I could do that I
could do that I can do that and I've got
400 unfinished projects yes half of a
marriage left how much money you spent
on half of it done I know it sucks we'll
see if we can book you on the podcast
John the list is long it's Ken Coleman
right out so that's a long list but we
have a lot of fun and of course we do
have a drink in every episode sometimes
it's a mocktail and we rate the drink we
tell you what's in it and how expensive
it is and we give it a rating and so
it's a quick piece of the podcast but it
makes it more fun we just wanted an
inviting environment you could talk
about money and send it to your friends
who may not listen to you know a few
hours of the Ramsay show or some of
these other shows it's just like a
little starting point for your friends
that don't know what we're all about
because money it is it's a threat in
every area of life so whether it's the
Royals we can talk about that that's
true our houses everything everything we
do we're gonna do one on tipping culture
which is very stressful can I tell you I
am a I believe deeply in over tipping
wow with all of my heart are you trying
to sell to get on that episode I I have
a firm commitment to uh I think one of
the greatest ways you can honor people
is just just tip like crazy wow I agree
okay well it's going to be a little bit
of episodes hey do you tip when they uh
when you when you go to buy food or
anything and they have the little thing
they give you your to-go you slide your
debit card in and then it says tip I'm
insecure
oh well you don't tell me twice John
break you I'm insecure what do you do
um sometimes sometimes if if you're not
doing anything if you're not adding any
if you're not if I'm not buying the
thing in your service then no but if I'm
buying into the service with this then
yes that's a fair point we might steal
your information and put it on the next
episode smart money happy well it is
it's skyrocketing in the charts and so
go check it out smart money happy hour
two episodes drop today new episodes
every single Thursday go listen follow
subscribe to Smart money happy hour
wherever you listen to podcasts share it
with friends it's been a fun day and it
will continue to be that's right George
thanks for coming on Cheers grab a drink
hang out with your friends smart money
happy hour we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com Ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey guys so we've all got things that we
went out alive with our money our
relationships our spiritual walk but
those results only happen when we're
intentional with them and we do things
on purpose and we really can start to
see things change so let's be honest we
don't always get the results we want
because we don't have the right tools
the right motivation so that's why I am
so pumped about the new 2023 Ramsay goal
planner so we took all your suggestions
from the last goal planner and we have
made a new one for this year and we are
so pumped about it so it is on sale now
and within it it has I mean well on it
it's a gorgeous beautiful cover me and
George design we all see that that's
right we handled the gold foil it's
beautiful we gold foiled it and John
George and myself have content all
through here on your spiritual walk on
your financial life and when it comes to
your relationship so there's good
content in it and it also just going to
help you stay organized if you love a
goal planner this one's for you and some
people are at people cool this isn't for
you but my wife is a big are you a goal
planner are you a planner person uh
I'm a calendar person calendar person
calendar yeah
my wife carries something around the
whole phone book yeah exactly Georgia
had a great goal planner like this one
so today's gonna be my year John well no
John you and I have talked about goals a
guy I created like 38 goals in every
area of life and then I would fail at 36
of them 37 of them you know exactly but
this one makes it very clear we have our
goal teaching inside of this and it
makes it easy to take the next step each
day with the teaching so I'm excited to
use it and be encouraged by YouTube yep
so you can get it at ramseysolutions.com
planner today it's beautiful it's
wonderful great content in there it's
everything you need and a greater gifts
yes all right let's go to John in
Detroit Rock City what's up John
Hi how are you doing good my man what's
up
uh so I'm just found out about you guys
recently as always
people scrolling through my Facebook
news feed the show started popping up so
I thought I'd ask since I saw one of
Dave's posts about the seven baby steps
I'm thinking about not contributing as
much to my retirement so I can get out
of debt and I'm wondering how much debt
I should pay off before I start
contributing to my retirement and how
much uh should I stop contributing to
get out of debt well first let me
welcome you to our gang man
um you're joining millions of people
who've decided I'm done living like I
was living I want something more for my
life so congratulations man
um hey we held George over he's we kept
him in the studio we locked the door so
we couldn't leave and this is a great
question for both of you all to walk our
Fringe on through yeah my take on this
John is you're joining a weird gang
which means we're doing weird things
that don't make sense culturally they
don't make sense on paper but they make
sense emotionally for my behavior change
so how much are you investing right now
what percentage
uh currently in going into my pre-tax is
18
my employer is contributing eight
percent so they will contribute four
percent whether I put in a penny or I
don't put in anything at all wow that's
incredible four percent match and you're
doing 18 of yours of your income
yes okay so on top of that I also
contribute 500 a month to my IRA okay
John I'm just like uh I felt my health
savings account every year as well okay
so in a rough estimate how much money is
that 18 for you per month just for
Math's sake
uh so that 18
it's the uh four percent I put in is
roughly 270 a month in the additional
percentage that I put in is about 912 a
month okay nice
so yeah what do you make a year
79 000 and change what's your total debt
load how much do you owe everything
so I've got a 177 000 on my mortgage
I've got about 34
000 in a home equity loan
and I've got about 7 800 in credit card
debt I've got no vehicle payments no
student loan payments uh unloaded at
those are it right there along with just
my mortgage and my utilities and
uh vehicle maintenance whatever else
comes up how much do you have in the
bank in cash liquid
uh liquid so in one account I've got
about 400 bucks I've got about 400 in
cash another account I've got about 2
400 bucks and then there's all my
retirement savings so you don't have
enough cash about 3 500 in the stock
markets okay
you've got a lot going on you're doing
about 17 things at once and you're doing
some great things but what we teach is
in order with focused intensity and
that's the baby steps so we would say
while you're paying off Consumer Debt so
ignore the mortgage for now we are going
to pause investing down to zero for a
short period of time because guess what
that frees up 1500 bucks a month that
you are throwing towards Investments are
now going to clean up this pile of debt
so what George is walking you through
this I'm going to pause right here I
know we know that sounds insane John
okay
everyone has told you since you were a
little kid that they made up some
Einstein quote that probably wasn't real
that
um if you just put a dollar in every day
you're gonna be a billionaire when
you're they you've been hearing that
since you were a child right and so
you're doing the right thing by by
focusing on retirement it feels so good
like you're getting ahead and you're
smart and you're making good money
hear me very clearly you are at risk
you're broke you owe a whole bunch of
money
okay so we're gonna clean that nonsense
up and so when George says stop stop
your first audience I'm just giving away
free I'm giving away free money I'm
gonna get a match just stop you're broke
you're broke you're broke let's clean
this dead up so we can get back on top
of it what's the interest rate on that
credit card
uh the credit card I don't remember the
percentage interest rate I know like on
my last statement that I just looked at
earlier today I paid like 200 interest
ouch my guess is probably 20 plus
an interest every single monthly so John
here's kind of the radical thing that
what we talk about is that that we have
a culture of doing exactly what you're
doing okay so you're doing 18 different
things you're taking your paycheck and
you're trying to do it all at once and
there's something powerful when you have
focused intensity on one thing one thing
only and so that's what we teach when we
say the first three baby steps we just
have one thousand dollar emergency fund
which you have
uh baby step two when you're doing and
getting out of debt stopping everything
and every penny that you have is going
towards this debt to get this momentum
and that means even I would cash out
what you have in stocks because it's not
within retirement so
I would do that and and all of a sudden
yeah and I even it was like 15 1700
bucks a month that you could have all
this credit card debt just cleaned up in
in three to four months if you really
get on it and you maybe even take a
second job and then that 34 or that yeah
that's thirty four thousand HELOC that
you have you could get that knocked out
John here in the next nine to 12 months
so there's just something powerful to
put a plan on paper to say wow what if I
had no payments that this credit card
debt is a hangover my head this HELOC
that I have over here that I know is
there and I'm kind of paying on it like
like all of that's gone all of that
could be gone in in 12 to 14 months
depending on how intense you get with
this and so the power of not having
those payments not only mathematically
freeze up your income but also just the
amount which we talk about a lot here is
just like the emotional freeze up your
soul it's just like sleeping John and be
like I don't sleeping at night and just
I have I have no one to pay yeah I have
no one to pay there's such freedom in
that and so walking that through is is
so important so like what George said at
the beginning of the call that it's
weird this is weird advice it's not
probably what your econ 101 Professor
would say uh but also this is the plan
millions of people have done because
money is is such a small percentage when
it comes just to the math the bulk of
personal finance is your behavior change
it is it is your behavior and what you
do with money and getting these wins
drawn under your belt for maybe the
first time in your life changes course
and changes the way that you view money
so if you hold on the line Austin is
going to pick up and give you Financial
Peace University I've been giving this
away I feel like the whole show because
it is it is the most powerful nine
lesson course John for you to walk
through and if you are married if you
have family do it do it all together and
and do this plan because there's
something powerful about having the
freedom of not having payments
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show let's go out to
Tim in Oklahoma City hey Tim what's up
man
hello what's up
oh I'm 53 years old I'm going through a
divorce
and I spent the last couple years as a
stay-at-home dad homeschooling my son
and I really I don't I don't have I
don't have anything I don't I mean the
baby statues
definitely where I'm at I wish I'd have
known about all this sooner in life
but I didn't have parents my mom taught
us to cocaine and lose and my dad taught
us to fight in booze
and now I'm going through a divorce my
wife's trajectory is
going out of the roof
she gets a lot of Facebook attention and
Instagram attention and that is a
contributing factor
but I don't I'm I'm I'm scared I'm 53
years old and I'm scared yeah because I
don't I don't I have the hero
I'm sorry man
that's not your fault no I know but
you're my brother and
um you know I mean my parents have some
brain but they don't
they've never been parents you know
that's right they did the best they
could do and it was really terrible you
know my Dad tried to throw me through a
plate glass windows yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I I know I know
and uh hold on hold on hold on
the moment it hurts
you start deflecting and want to go
backwards you want to go forward you
want to talk about them you talk about
someone else
yeah I just sit in it for a second okay
it hurts
because out of what out of this hurt
right here we call it grief
out of this comes that scary terrifying
question
what are you gonna do next
exactly okay
and I think with all my heart
um you've got childhood traumas that are
killing you from the inside out I have
no doubt about that yes
um I bet you've got regrets with your
kids you have kids
okay
disappearance different Motors okay
you've had a long road right
yeah I'm tired there you go
tired I can hear it I can hear it in you
um
I don't know what to do I mean like I
said I'm 53 it's it's literally starting
over I have I'm frozen another bank
account
I live day to day uh
on
just trying to get by actually you know
yep and uh I you know
I don't I'm I'm I'm my body's broken I
can't do construction like I did I live
in rural community uh the largest
metropolitans I don't live in Oklahoma
City for sale is outside Oklahoma City
it's an hour and a half away okay
are you ready for everything to be
different
yeah I've been chasing different my
whole life and every time I do it wrong
okay
who's somebody you can call right now
that's a friend
an old friend somebody Trust
I mean I do but I I don't no no no you
do you don't want to
I don't want anyone to know how bad it
is and you know what that is that's
shame my brother and that will kill you
I have a lifetime of it I know Secrets
will kill you
you know you if you look at Facebook
I could care less about
Facebook it's a fantasy it's not right
but careless about Facebook Instagram
all that crap could care less you need a
real friend in your life that you can
look at and say I don't know what to do
next
and the moment you say that in the
presence of somebody else that you love
and trust you will feel lighter than you
have felt in 30 years
yeah I have I've reached out and I get
the
I mean people love me but they don't
know how to help me okay it's got to be
a both hand
okay you need to sit down with someone
and say I need help making a plan
whether that's a pastor whether that's a
local counselor at a Community
Counseling Center that's not going to
charge you anything whether that's a
friend that you trust that owns a
business that you you have a sketchy
past with because you've messed them
over a few times I've not ever done that
I know hey I'm just putting it out there
brother I'm on your team
I'm just saying the time for ego and the
time for Pride it helps people and I
couldn't even help myself let's left the
building
and
you happen to have hit the bottom
in the single greatest job economy in
the history of this country
and Now's the Time to go to Taco Bell
Now's the Time to go work at Arby's now
is the time to go I agree I agree I'm
just so far away and then like then then
it's time then listen joint custody of
my son so I every other day you know I
just and I don't have a support group
like she does she has her parents
Tim
you're gonna have to make some
short-term sacrifices to turn your thing
around
I don't want to abandon my son I know
but in an effort to not quote unquote
abandon him you're going to drown
yourself
in six months of going to get yourself
financially stable getting a place to
live
getting a job or two jobs or three jobs
getting some not respect from your
community but respect from that guy you
see in the mirror because you don't like
that guy
getting some respect back from that guy
is going to come back and you're going
to be six inches taller with that little
boy
mentally I need my son though because I
don't nope nope I don't have anybody
else and I feel I already feel like he
he aligns with his mom and he pulls away
and when the daisy pulls away I almost
can't deal with it
because like I can't go into how bad it
was for me I tried my whole life to get
my love for my mother and she's been
nothing but cruel
I was suicidal at one time and you know
she didn't care
and you know sometimes you just want
that parent to say hey
and I'm never going to get that okay
I don't want to do that to my son Tim
where are you living right now
right now in the marital house until
uh she's at her parents is that a month
from now how far away until you don't
have a place to live anymore
a couple of probably about a week okay
so that is our A1 we've got to have
somewhere to live you're not going to be
homeless you got to take care of your
son we got to put food on the table do
you have any bills that you have to pay
any debt
I'm I let my truck go back I have no
debt I have I have I have no doubt how
much money do you have in the bank
nothing zero dollars zero dollars okay
then we gotta go to work today and we
gotta find a local community a local
church and we've got to let them know
that you are not doing well and that you
need some help right now and see what
they can do for you that might be a roof
over your head that might be some a meal
but you gotta stop living alone
and you can't put this on your son
in a group of 100 people I'm alone Tim
do you abuse your son
no hell no okay listen listen do you
abandon your son
I feel like I'm gonna have to in order
to get on my feet there is nothing
similar about you and your mom
there is nothing good things on purpose
listen to me listen to me you are not
your mom you are not your dad
your separation from your son for six
months to go somewhere where you can
actually get work
and get yourself straightened out
get yourself some counseling that you
need is not abandonment that's called
love
don't tell me that people get who go on
deployment or abandoning their kids or
people who go to to rehab for 30 days or
60 days or 90 days or six months or
abandoning their kids they're not
because getting yourself Tim in the most
stable healthiest position
emotionally financially all of this that
is the biggest gift you can give to your
son
because when you are you know even the
conversation we're having right now
uh the the kind of the back and forth I
mean I I hear the pain I hear the pain
in your voice and the story that you've
been through I can't even imagine
and the best thing you can do Tim for
your son the biggest gift you can give
him is is a healthy dad a dad that is
supporting himself that may not it may
not be it's not going to be the luxury
life on Facebook like you're comparing
it to none of that like cut all that out
but to have a dad who is stable and can
love him well with a full healthy heart
that is the biggest gift you can give
him to him so you're not abandoning him
you're doing something you're giving him
a gift by doing this you can do it all
today let some people know I'm not okay
I'm ready to go to work
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsay show do you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where dead is dumb cash is
king and the paid off mortgage has taken
the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice I'm John deloney joined
here by my good friend and best-selling
author Rachel Cruz and we are taking
your calls on money life work
relationships whatever you got going on
in your life we'll walk alongside you
and help you make the next right
decision triple eight eight two five
five two two five is triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go out
to Andrew in Lexington Kentucky what's
up Andrew
Hi how are you all doing today I'm good
my brother what's up
I am currently in baby step number two
and I have a question about putting it
on pause for a moment because I want to
take Dave's advice and sell the truck
awesome so where where are you at in the
debt snowball how much do you have left
um right now I'm told that is 86
640 what kind of debt is that
um Pal's car truck credit cards and
school take your house out
um 45 000 on the house and the rest is
all the other day so you got about 45
Grand left just to be able to breathe a
little bit
yes sir okay awesome and so if you and
the truck is included in the Consumer
Debt
yes ma'am and that so how much when you
pay that off what difference like what
will you be left with
well the Chuck's value is roughly around
25
000. nice probably sell but I owe 9 000
on it so I'm wanting to be gazelle
intense by selling it and that's the
reason why I want to pause baby step
number two to buy a daily driver to get
back and forth to work to replace this
vehicle yeah for sure so yeah when we
talk about pausing the debt snowball the
one reason we'd say is if you're getting
married uh one would be if you're having
a baby uh one would be if you have to
save up for something if something at
your house breaks uh you know you can
pause save up some cash to replace the
water heater or whatever it may be and
the car is another one as well so how
much do you make how much you make a
year
um 86 000 roughly okay that's great
so the only thing here Andrew is when
you're when you're pausing to save up
for a car you're not saving up for a
nice car do you agree
yes ma'am the car I'm looking at is uh
it's like a little two-door Acura yeah
boy look at that guy perfect how much is
it
it is 3 000 on Marketplace right now
that's what I'm talking perfect Andrew
yes so yeah so if if you're asking is it
okay to pause baby step two to save up
that three Grands because you're gonna
be selling the truck uh then yep
absolutely so real quick on the math you
gotta you're gonna get 25 grand for this
truck you owe nine on it that's gonna
leave you a 16 Grand you're gonna buy a
3 000 car with cash
um or they're asking for three so you're
gonna pay twenty seven hundred dollars
in cash for this car and the rest that
13 000 plus is gonna go straight to your
debt
yes sir it's gonna pay off all the
credit card debt and everything it
should pay almost everything but maybe
school and cars so it should leave me
around 28 000 if I'm not mistaken
awesome and with your income which is
you're crushing it you're talking six
more months and you're done with this
mess right
yes sir dude congratulations man that's
awesome way to go all that transaction
and stuff so you're what's your plan
though to pause for like a month just to
get all this settled and that's it
possible thing 13 seconds right
yeah just for a month yes ma'am and I
wish it was 13 seconds Dr John but I
mean the pause should be just as long as
it really with the transaction with the
bank getting the money putting the money
over buying the car making sure the
title's good like just like that just
the groundwork I just threw out a month
it could be oh two weeks two weeks yeah
okay uh the groundwork to transition
correct Andrew we're on the same page
right yes ma'am perfect okay
hey that 13 000 bucks you have left is
gonna burn a hole through your pocket
get yeah get rid of it okay get rid of
it on debt yes sir here's my fear about
pausing for a month is you sell your car
you get 25 000 you go to the the bank
and you get your title you trade all the
turn all that stuff over
you got 16 000 bucks and it's like this
is nice that could be a five thousand
dollar car we get a 10 let's get a ten
thousand dollar card and all of a sudden
man you're it's not quite as it just
cracked up to me so I love that you have
it already picked out that's a great tip
for people listening that are in this
exact same position like find the car
and be like this is the car so that you
don't do this like going shopping hungry
like yeah yeah don't do this not like
this lifestyle creep of oh well there's
a there's a there's a kind of a nicer
one we could we could just spend two
grand more and get that so yeah have it
picked out
yeah be focused on Andrew and that's
great that's awesome I'm proud of you
man all right let's go to Orion in San
Diego California what's up Ryan
[Music]
hey how's it going outstanding we're up
against the clock so get right to your
question for me what's up
all right cool so um
I'm married I have two sons
two years old and a 10 month old and my
wife and I just want to move next spring
up north to Washington okay uh we're
talking to lenders and we got approved
for 350 000.
and I have 92 in unusual sun and another
22 and another neutral fund
and about seven Grand in savings so I
wanted to know is it wise to use
those mutual funds and
put it all down on the house or
I mean like what like what what I'm just
looking for advice on that because I'm
kind of discussed yeah do you have any
other just liquid savings besides the
7000 everything else is tied up in
Investments
correct correct okay are those
retirement mutual funds are they just
off to the side
there's off to the side one was one that
my grandmother was saving up for me for
a while and then the other one started
out at 100 000 from her life insurance
policy that she left with me okay do you
have
um
retirement somewhere else with something
else
yeah so I got my 401k that I'm starting
and I have 10 in my Roth and then five
percent in that with about a four
percent match on my 401k okay I mean how
much will you for your house currently
what's your living situation how will
that change when you guys move what do
you owe in your house
yeah we're living with her parents
they've been gracious enough to help us
out
um
because I kind of went belly up when I
was renting so my wife did pay off all
of her debt and I was trying to do it
all okay
she was able to become debt free so we
were both debt free
um in a monthly payments on stuff we
actually are have to pay or it's about
spent on the bus you you broke up yeah
how much is it talk directly on your
phone
oh uh 600 bucks a month that we actually
have to pay okay so you guys have no
debts your seven thousand dollars is
liquid with savings
um I guess like for an emergency fund or
something and then you have all this
other stuff so
um
yeah if I mean man I'd cash them out I'd
cash out but I would I would say keep
bump up that seven thousand dollars to a
three to six months worth of expenses
and just because you guys qualify for
350 around I would really encourage you
just because that's what the bank will
give you doesn't mean that you need it
make sure you get a 15-year fixed rate
and that the mortgage payment is no more
than 25 of your take-home pay work on
that formula versus what the bank the
bank will give you a bunch but that
doesn't mean you can afford it so run
those numbers very very carefully uh but
yeah you can cash out those mutual funds
and use it as a down payment on probably
a mortgage less than 350. probably 250
yeah just to be conservative you're good
and you can always move again in a few
years if you want whatever
hey Triple Eight two five five two two
five we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five find
out for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window covering you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code Ramsay to get the
best deal today's question comes from
John in Arizona I'm a strong believer in
paying cash for cars and living a
debt-free life as I just paid off my
student loans and officially kicked
Sallie Mae out of the house
unfortunately my father believes in
financing cars and laughs at me my gosh
sorry John laughs at me when I tell him
that he should pay cash last time I told
him he got aggressive and cost a rift in
the family
how do I help my dad stop being a slave
to the lender and live a debt-free life
you don't John you don't yeah it's not
your job to do that can I be oh my God
this may be rude I don't care John you
caused the riff he doesn't want to hear
what you have to say he never has
and my guess is he's not dumb he's just
chosen to live differently and let him
he thinks you're dead make the choice
either I'm just gonna love my dad and my
dad's gonna say Dad things
and then we're gonna go better life or
just don't don't be around him but to
keep bringing this up and keep bringing
it up finally he's just snapped at you
John you're one of those you know
we get fees and marriages where one is
just like
they're not doing this I'm like you're
you're a little like I appreciate the
enthusiasm but like let's simmer down a
little bit You're Gonna Lose everyone in
your life so chill it's okay uh yeah
John it's not your uh not your
responsibility just take 30 off 40 off
man just the SMH moments with parents
just shake my head you just kind of
grand and you just you just Emoji in the
real world you just just have that John
you're good Let It Go Let It Go and by
the way parents
when your kids are zealous and they come
to you with their excitement and their
Joy about their whatever
it's dragons or potions or unicorns or
when they grow up and they come to you
with Ramsey Solutions be kind just be
kind Just Go With It Go With It Go with
it there's no reason to get aggressive
and cause riffs just go that life is too
short and on a serious note I've just I
can't Rachel I can't get out of my head
the number of people I've sat with that
either their parents just died or their
kids just it is they have never been
like you know what I'm really glad I put
my foot down about I borrow money I
borrow money to buy cars that's never
ever come up yeah they always I wish I
could have this conversation back I wish
I could just have five more minutes okay
I wish I got five more minutes so take
all the minutes you got while you got
them and don't fight over dumb things
that's it that's all I have to say about
that good job let's go to Dan Dan let's
go to Dan in Boston what's up Dan
hey you guys thanks for uh taking my
call appreciate it you got it Dan thanks
for calling what's up
uh in our 60s wife and I
um we just finished baby step two in
March
and are now on baby step three we're
packing the money away for six months of
our emergency fund awesome congrats man
thanks thank you thank you so much uh
but um
the question is I know in baby step four
it's 15 and then throw the rest of the
money up uh to the house but we're in
our 60s we only have 130 Grand in a 401k
um we allow we're allowed to do a um a
catch up I guess
and can we max out
um if we were to max out my 401k it'd be
like what I'm allowed to do is like 22
percent of my cat my salary instead of
the 15
and my company is awesome there's a nine
percent match
um can we go with the 22 or should we
keep it at 15 and then all the extra
money go towards the house yeah at your
age I would go ahead and do the 22 so
once you can kind of hit that rate when
you're
um where you guys are at I would be
investing more and then you can throw
the rest at the house um but I would
yeah catch up as much as you can
um
to retirement because you guys are you
guys are getting I do have like the age
that you really want to retire do you
have that that magical age right now you
wish you could I won 62. that isn't
gonna work yeah how much you owe in your
house man
uh a house is working around it's over
six and we owe 204. okay
and if we can put you know 27 Grand a
year in a 401k my company matches nine
percent
um on my salary
so that's
that's you know if we could do that for
seven years
yeah chunk of change yeah and it it'll
it the rates the historical rates it
will double about every seven seven and
a half years on you
um I also would love to see y'all get
rid of that last lingering liability
which is your mortgage as you head into
retirement years
um what what is your current income
uh the both of us combined about 140. oh
fantastic okay so you could Max this out
and
if y'all went after it for a couple of
years you could max out your 401 and
knock this house out too
that would be hard of course it would
Dan nothing's fun when it when you're
when you when you're trying to you know
cross the finish line right
yep
um but yeah it would be really tough but
man I'd love to just imagine yourself
65.
you own your house your half a million
dollar house outright
you're on your way to building
retirement and now you're having
different conversations because you have
no liabilities right you just got to tax
an insurance bill at that point right
right yeah my wife is pushing to go to
15 and just throw it all at the house to
get it paid off
uh if you guys weren't at this age then
yes I would agree yeah it's an age thing
at this point and when you're able to
kind of do the catch up on all the
retirement stuff I would take advantage
of that
okay
cool congratulations man hey can I can I
tell you like you're inspiring man
oh thank you not like the one of the the
most common things I hear is I'm too
young to do this or
um 55 and it's it's all over for me I
can't start anything new and so to see
somebody at 62 saying no no I've been
grinding I've got this thing done and
now I'm going to the next step that's
that's awesome dude
yeah we uh it was kind of scary because
we finally got uh my wife's niece did
this crazy thing they got into a cult
and
they started taking everything off and
getting second jobs and selling the car
and next thing you know she's working
for the cult down in Tennessee oh is she
here is she a team member
oh she is so fun
help
they had a really nice car in that
crappy car and they sold a nice car
because they were money on it and they
went down to one car and you know
carpooling to to work and but hey as you
as you got to listen to their story you
probably heard them smiling a little bit
more and laughing a little bit deeper
yep yeah yeah
um yeah her name's Ashley she works for
you guys so much
and then we we started looking at this
like you know we got that so it's crazy
as soon as soon as we as soon as we paid
off our credit card uh we had always had
credit card debt as soon as we cut it up
paid it off I lost my job
wow wow dang so now we're in like yeah
Crush mode and you know it just and make
a long story short 26 months 89 Grand
gone unbelievable brother well I can't
tell you how awesome it is and we've had
a well-do we had a roof go and
appliances go our house is 20 years old
but we paid cash wow amazing how does
that feel people listening right now Dan
sounds awesome it's just I can't tell
you how about how how great it is way to
go down dude
appreciate it thank you my brother it's
never too late
all you have to say is I'm gonna make
this happen and then you gotta go do it
gotta go do it we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five if
you're looking to sell your house right
now it can be overwhelming
some markets homes are selling so fast
and for more than their asking price
that other markets are showing signs of
slowing down it's just a mess and it's a
lot to navigate but look you don't have
to sell your home alone and you know
what you shouldn't it's important to
have a real estate agent who knows your
local housing market inside and out and
who will walk you through the process
you need an indoors local provider by
your side our elps are Ramsay trusted
which means they're highly vetted
top-tier real estate agents our team
trusts these are Pros who are excited to
serve you and help you sell your home at
the right price if you're ready to sell
your home get a Ramsay trusted ELP in
your corner it's free to connect today
just go to ramsesolutions.com agent to
find one near you that's
ramseysolutions.com
agent all right let's go to Carol in the
beautiful Mesa Arizona what's up Carol
hi good afternoon you two thanks for
taking my call you got it what's up so
my no so my husband and I have just
started taking Financial fees after 20
years of waiting for him to get on board
he's right here with me and he is so
gung-ho he is ready to get rid of our
second car we have our second class
tonight and
um there's a lot of reasons that getting
rid of the second car would be good but
uh it just seems like a really fast big
thing to do before we have everything
under our feet yet so fast you've been
waiting for 20 years for this yeah
they've only been the one class
oh so he he he's he's in he's that kid
that sits on the side of the pool and
waits and waits and waits and then drops
the ultimate Cannonball right
clearly yes
what's your financial position uh how
much do you owe how much do you make all
that stuff
Okay so
okay circuit because I've been
a demo let's at least 150 000 It's a
combination of
um cars credit cards
um IRS debt uh we also uh we bring home
I say we're in the neighborhood of a
hundred thousand dollars a year
um maybe a little bit more he's a home
health nurse so he has the potential to
make additional money
um and that's kind of where
we're starting how much you owe the IRS
oh I really don't want to say it's very
embarrassing hey we are way past that
what is it we've heard it all Carol
we've heard it all
part
I at least 70 maybe more okay we'll see
we'll say 75 to be safe just to round it
up how much for uh of of the second car
is he gonna sell
I mean I asked that is that in a wonky
way how much money are you going to walk
away from selling that second car
uh we would probably have to come up
with an additional 700 to pay it off
maybe 800. we are upside down
yes yes okay what's your payment every
month what would you net the next month
um it would be
it's like 5 25 a month
okay
another car how much do you owe on the
other car
uh we owe more
um that one we owe probably an
additional ten thousand I mean like less
is left does that make sense
a lot that we owe like wait a minute I
didn't give you the right number we've
paid a lot that we owe probably in the
20s at least so you owe 20 000 and how
much can you sell that car for
um not as much as the first car
much if you Kelly Blue booked it right
now how much could you sell that before
I would literally have the Kelly Blue
Book and I'm so sorry I know you're fine
no no you're fine I would I would run
some numbers because if there's any time
to sell cars it's right now in this
market it's getting
you know the the market is Shifting
where it's not becoming as wonderful to
to uh sell used cars but right now
they're so high so I would look honestly
Carol at selling both and getting two
beaters is what you guys can do now
you're gonna owe some monies you're
gonna have to take out a small loan on
the difference but at least you just
don't have that massive two massive car
payments every month that's going to
free you guys up so I would because and
Carol too because I'm looking at your
numbers you guys make a hundred you owe
a hundred and fifty thousand which I
know a big part of that is IRS but you
guys gotta just do some radical stuff
you've been waiting 20 years he's been
five minutes into this plan he's ready
to do it like just go scorched earth
like I feel like you guys need a radical
shakeup so if I were you guys I would
sell everything I would sell everything
I would sell the cars I would look
around your house crap you have
we just downsized last year and got rid
of everything that we would have sold
well that's fine that's fine okay and
then he needs to pick up extra work I
mean there there has to be a radical
change here Carol because even though
you've had this feeling for 20 years you
guys have been in the same habits and
the same decision-making mindset for 20
years so to change that that's kind of
like moving the Titanic I mean it's not
like you guys are 25 and you're starting
everything out you're having to for
decades of what you've known is about to
be uprooted and I really I mean I would
I would go extreme Carol just to shake
it up in your spirits just to say we're
doing this like we're doing it because
here's the deal too Carol you can always
go a little scary
but it's also scary to be 150 000 in
debt making a hundred grand that's scary
so here's the deal it's stuff okay and
that's what I want you to remember this
is all just stuff you can go back and
get you some stuff we're not against
stuff we actually would love for you
guys and a few years to buy awesome cars
call us back and be like look we're debt
free and have awesome cars that's great
that's what we want for you but for
right now Carol you guys need this you
need a you need a massive shake-up so
I'd be selling everything and then
cleaning up the IRS step first yeah the
IRS debt really I don't like it makes me
super uncomfortable you all need to go
scorched Earth to get rid of that one
yes I'm talking he's worked seven days a
week
yeah you move that to the front top of
the yes yes okay and that's a big one
and it's going to be a pain to pay off
because you're gonna drop 10 grand
you're gonna just collapse and have ten
thousand it's still gonna have sixty
thousand left to go on it I don't care
you got to keep grinding away at that
one because they can start garnishing
wages I mean they they will this is
serious yes that's the only type of debt
we say to move up on the debt snowball
um
so you guys got to clean that up and
it's going to help with getting these
car payments out that you won't have the
car payments you're gonna free up some
cash and you're gonna be able to feel
the snowball rolling with both of you
working girl can I ask you a hard
question okay
maybe oh I'm going to you can just hang
up on me how about that Hey listen I may
be wrong here okay
are you somebody that likes the idea of
things
but doesn't like the actual execution of
him are you somebody who googles workout
programs but working out is not fun
no I just don't work out um here's what
I'm asking I'm wondering if part of your
husband's hesitation over 20 years is
part he's a knucklehead just like I am
but part he knows oh geez we're gonna go
do this thing and we're gonna get into
it and Carol's not going to want to go
all the way through with it
well no I I really do because I do see
that we absolutely have to make some
changes to
um get to where we want to be we are
both on the same page finally so
um yeah so I guess I just need to feel
the fear and do it anyway yes yeah yes
what's what scares you about it and we
said sell both cars and get two junkers
like what's the what's this what when
you said oh that's so scary what is
scary about that so so we've been trying
to practice being a single-part family
this week before we actually pull the
trigger and um so far so good we've done
two days but today I have a commitment I
have to leave you know very soon to go
take care of this issue with one of my
clients and we opted to go ahead and do
two cars today instead of stick to the
one and figure out how to how to make
that work with one car if you've got
mobile clients and he's a travel nurse I
don't see a way you can do y'all might
not be a two one car family so do two
two crappy cars sell them both and buy
two five thousand dollar cars
okay and you're yeah you're gonna want
to park three houses down from your
actual client's house because that's how
embarrassing you're gonna be about the
car and who cares let that be a
motivator for you to grind and grind and
grind Rachel said it you said it's so
good Rachel it is scorched Earth time it
is shake the snow globe it's do ever no
don't shake the snow globe throw it up
against the side of the house and blow
it up you got to do everything different
because the same normal has gotten you
to this point and to do the same and
normal moving forward you're gonna stay
in the same place blow it all up get
radical with it you can do it
congratulations
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
today's scripture of the day is
Colossians 3 17. and whatever you do
whether in word or deed you would all in
the name of Lord Jesus giving him thanks
to God the Father through him Hunter
Patch Adams says I dove into an Endless
Sea of gratitude from which I've never
emerged oh can I say like a probably
semi dumb comment here on the road on
the radio show the podcast I like how
you're asking for permission uh Patch
Adams I didn't know that was a
true story
the movie really yeah yeah I don't think
I knew that there's this cool thing
right when it starts
um it says based on a true story yeah I
mean it's a conspiracy theory huh years
since I've seen that movie and they only
stories are true that aren't true and
ones that aren't
the doctors come out and say hey this is
what we need to do to all be healthy and
she's like whatever and then a movie
comes out it's like based on a true
story and she's like whatever whatever
good job I didn't know that that I just
have a quote from that movie it's the
only quote that I know for that movie
and the old lady was like I just want to
swim in a big pool of noodles do you
remember that nope it's like they asked
like what your dream is and they send
the old lady and she swims in a big pool
of noodles it's great but anyways never
knew never knew true story though we're
changing lives in America we are
changing lives all right on that note
big gulps huh pick them up let's go to
Phillips in Dayton what's up Phillips
hello how are you I'm excellent how are
you
good good thank you for taking my call
so right now my wife and I are on baby
stuff too and um we're in the process of
getting out of debt by next year uh with
the other day next year so we're having
a lot more discussion on uh getting a
house once we complete baby soak three
well uh right now we just can't seem to
agree on the idea of you know a credit
score and um essentially why it's
um how it impacts your interest rate and
thus your monthly payment and things
like that so I wanted to call you guys
to get your take on it
um I know obviously what you guys
believe about credit scores but they
seem to be in disagreement on the value
of building credit scores towards you
know getting a lower interest rate and
whatnot for our home when that comes
yeah I mean it kind of honestly I've
heard all over the map depending on what
whether you go through a credit union
mortgage company all of it what kind of
rate that they give you without a credit
score when they do manual underwriting
some we've heard that it can be a little
bit higher uh some we've heard it's the
same and so it really is going to depend
when you guys pull those numbers when
you get close to it but as you guys are
getting out of debt it's still there's a
um a mental shift there that when you
say I'm not going to live with debt and
you go through baby step two you pay off
all of your debts naturally your credit
score is going to lower so you guys will
be using manual underwriting at some
point because you are not interacting
with debt if that's what you choose to
do
um but let me say this
um I
no she had no dad and as a part of my I
rented my home from the University where
I worked yeah and then when I went and
bought a house we ended death for years
we had no problem and so I I I didn't
haven't personally experienced that
right not having it because she's not
having a good relationship with debt not
like yeah
um and it wasn't like I was making a
billion dollars or anything like that
sure sure it was just I I just didn't
run into the problem and so I I know
there are people who sit down with their
mortgage lender and walk away and want
to point at this or point at that thing
if you're in good shape financially and
you've got a good down payment and you
sit down and you're buying a reasonable
house and if you have to go through the
manual underwriting process you have to
but I just I just I went through it
recently just didn't well it wasn't the
End of Time yeah
uh Phillips have you actually sat down
with a mortgage lender yet
um no we haven't I mean well we we've
talked to one just kind of briefly to
kind of because essentially her credit
technically is better than mine because
right now
um mine was just lower so they just they
told us the difference of what the
manual underwriting process would be you
know and how they would kind of Base it
off of mine because it's technically
lower right now
um it's not yet at that zero point that
you guys talk about yet did you go
through Churchill yeah Churchill yes
okay and so they said the manual
underwriting would be a little bit
higher
well no they didn't say that
um they didn't say like what the the
actual payment would be and that's why I
was calling uh okay
yeah I would sit down and say hey we're
ready to get this process started and uh
let's
let me put it this way my wife and I
have spent a lot of energy having
hypothetical arguments that once we just
got real numbers to real things it
settled the argument in an embarrassing
way so I would call and get some true
data and say all right let's assume
we're pulling the trigger here what is
this actually going to look like and
what are the dollars and cents to this
yeah and honestly Phillips where you
guys are you're still getting out of
debt you still want to save up an
emergency fund and you still want to
save a down payment you guys still could
be 18 24 however months out and even the
FED just raised the rate last yesterday
something like things are just
constantly changing in that world
anyways so um so I yeah I mean I would
if you want to do exactly what John said
I think that's great
don't do what I said do it
you do but but just know life could look
a whole lot different when you're
actually ready to purchase a home so
just remember that
um because again I think we can get
stuck in what today is and it that might
not be the case who who the heck knows
what 24 months he's gonna be in in
um in my world the mental health world
the nutrition and exercise space this
sounds like one of those worlds where
people are arguing over macro
percentages like how many grams of
protein how much this and how much that
and they don't exercise right like you
missed the big thing and you start
fighting over these little things the
big thing in Phillips home right now is
let's get out of that yeah like that's
the big that's that's the thing we can
do right now arguing about something
that's 24th or six months it's just it's
just bringing chaos into our home that
is unnecessary at this moment totally
and then and kind of I was gonna make
the point earlier and didn't really
finish it in my head but just this idea
that you know when you guys kind of like
are like oh do we do we kind of keep a
better credit score here kind of still
play the game here just to get the
credit scores
all of that back and forth honestly it's
not worth it like just saying we're
gonna be sticking to one plan we're
gonna focus on this and go all the way
through knowing that we can still get a
house at the end of it
there's just something that that does in
your behavior and in your spirit when
you commit to something versus this like
back and forth back and forth place and
when somebody tells me it's going to
cost you a quarter of a percentage point
if I'm in a financial position where
that prohibits me from buying the house
I shouldn't be buying the house right so
yeah good call go all in man go all in
and save that save that argument or that
frustration or that disagreement in your
home first hey it's something that
matters
um and be something that make when it's
time relevant right all right let's take
one more call let's run to Jason in
Atlanta Jason we are way up because the
clocks will get right to your question
hey guys
um so I just started listening to you
guys
um yeah recently and my wife and I are
just trying to figure out the best way
to do baby step number two which is
tackling our debt and um we feel like
um maybe our biggest obstacle is living
in the house that we're living in now uh
we just recently bought this house
um it's within the 25 range of our
take-home pay
um but we were just wondering if we need
to sell the house and downsize to kind
of remove what we think is the biggest
obstacle to paying our debt
um how much do you owe quickest way I
can answer the questions
how much do you owe
um oh gosh uh let's see four hundred and
one thousand dollars are you a doctor
uh we are both nurse practitioners okay
how much y'all bring in a year
uh 170. okay each are combined
uh combined why
um what do you mean
um
my I I've just got a limited number of
friends that are MPS out in the
community and they're both doing they're
they're that's about a salary for one of
them
gotcha so she's starting out so she's
this is her first year out of school and
I'm in a Ministry position where we like
serve the people who are underinsured
and so I'm going to tell you something
really hard Jason and uh I'm a person
who believes deeply in service and my
family very very similar you can't
afford to do that yet you put yourself
in such a hole that you're gonna have to
put your ministry on on pause and you're
gonna have to go earn a whole bunch of
money to clean this because I'm going to
assume if it's a lot of student loan
debt to get those degrees you guys have
a lot of debt so probably too much Grand
yes yeah that it that it may not be may
not be worth living in even though
you're in the 25 you could probably stay
it's not in your whole budget but hey uh
you could sell it I'm so sorry to be
that one but yeah you got to get after
it want to thank the great Bob orquez
for loving us and taking care of us
in Austin and James this has been the
Ramsey Show
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]